11 uhr heute morgen eine grundschule in
aachen der cdu kanzler kandidat armin
laschet wirft seinen wahlzettel in die
urne und wenn sie ganz genau hinschauen
dann sehen sie zwei blaue kreuz bei der
cdu
nun ist es keine überraschung dass der
cdu kanzlerkandidat die cdu wählt aber
die frage und deshalb bis jan schäfer
hier bei uns mit im studio ist ob diese
stimme überhaupt noch gültig ist sich
darf mal aus der homepage des
bundeswahlleiters zitieren das
bundeswahlgesetz dort heißt es sie
müssen in der wahlkabine ihren
stimmzettel so
falten dass ihre wahlentscheidung nicht
erkennbar ist nur so kann das
wahlverfahren ordnungsgemäß ablaufen und
das wahlgeheimnis gewahrt werden
außerdem heißt es das wahlgeheimnis ist
verletzt sobald der ausgefüllte und in
die urne geworfen stimmzettel einer
person zugeordnet werden kann das heißt
also das wahlgeheimnis ist durch armin
laschet hier ganz klar verletzt worden
denn jeder kann sehen wem er seine
stimme gegeben hat thomas wir haben es
hier mit der ersten wirklich schweren
wahlpanne dieses wahltages zu tun
ausgerechnet armin laschet ausgerechnet
der kanzlerkandidaten und
energie das ist nicht überraschend dass
er die cdu mit beiden stimmen das muss
man auch mal sagen aber du hast es auch
gerade aus dem wahlgesetz vorgelesen die
stimmabgabe ist geheim so jetzt die
große frage was passiert hat armin
laschet das bewusst gemacht wir haben
ein paar juristen auch telefoniert die
sagen na ja das kann man ihm eigentlich
nicht so richtig unterstellen dass er
das bewusst gemacht hat wir haben auch
die bilder gesehen ist war jetzt kein
moment in dem man noch mal den
stimmzettel direkt offensiv in die
kamera gehalten hat und gesagt hat leute
guck mal ich hab mit beiden stimmen
überraschenderweise cdu gebeten ein so
kann man das nicht sagen und wir haben
und ich habe auch gesehen wie er den
stimmzettel reingesteckt in die urne das
war ein normaler vorgang und wir wissen
ist von
spitzenkandidaten ja immer ein bisschen
warten an der urne das noch fotos
gemacht werden jetzt ist das foto in der
welt wie gesagt die große frage wird
sein gibt es jetzt protest die wahl
könnte natürlich damit angefochten
werden wenn man das gesetz ganz ganz
streng nimmt und dann wird es der reine
stimme könnte nicht genauso ist es so
und dann muss der bundeswahlleiter am
ende als letzte instanz müsste darüber
entscheiden du hast gerade eben auch
gesagt kann man diesen stimmzettel
nachvollziehen ja er hat ja sehr dick
seine kreuze markiert das wird
sicherlich eine sisyphus-arbeit in
dieser warnung daher sind gibt aber
meine schönsten genaue uhrzeit wir haben
ja durch den screenshot gemacht wurde
können wir genau sehen wir können
rückwärts sogar den countdown ein bei
bild.de wir rückwärts laufen lassen
können wir genau zuordnen das war gegen
11 uhr 10 man könnte es auf die sekunde
genau aber dann ist es so in dieser
wahlurne mischen sich alle wahlzettel
und am ende wird die urne geöffnet und
dann wird sie umgedreht und in der regel
ausgeschüttet auf einem tisch so dass
man gar nicht mehr genau sagen kann war
das jetzt jemand der die stimme um 9 uhr
abgegeben hat oder war es jemand der die
stimme um 11 26 ab die linien arbeiten
seine frau susanne asche die auf
jeden fall ihre finger über die kräuter
hält sieht man hier ganz genau während
armin laschet also hier ganz deutlich
zeigt ob willentlich oder nicht wen er
gewählt hat und du hast das gesagt die
kreuze sind sehr dick das könnte
vielleicht wieder auffindbar sein haben
wir gesehen dass seine frau susanne ganz
geschickt vielleicht auch per zufall auf
jeden fall ganz geschickt die finger
über den wahlzettel hält also ist es
merkwürdig dass überhaupt jemand
aufgepasst hat im wahllokal ich habe
heute in berlin gewählt und da wurde
mehrmals ganz darauf hingewiesen dass
der wahlzettel nach innen geklappt
werden müssen also dass man gerade an
der wahlurne auch nicht sieht was gesagt
wurde was man selbst gewählt hatten das
auch gar nicht zu sehen ist welche
parteien antreten als erwartet wird nach
innen zusammengeklappt und deswegen ist
es durchaus bemerkenswert dass auch
niemand in dem wahlbüro also nicht der
chef dieses wahlbüros oder andere
beteiligte gesagt haben herr laschet sie
müssten eigentlich ihren wahlzettel
anders kaliber laschet sie haben es auch
falsch grund und jahren wir haben als
wir live kommentiert haben haben noch
darüber gesprochen dass es
sehr lange dauert als armin laschet noch
mal die unterlagen vor zeigte am ende
bzw die letzten
formalitäten erledigen musste saß er
hinter ihm saß ein mann hinter einem
schalter hinter einer plexiglasscheibe
ich weiß nicht ob man das am anfang des
videos auch gesehen hat und sie haben da
wirklich zwei minuten lang noch
verbracht und wir haben die zeit noch
hier versucht zu überbrücken das heißt
da hat jemand noch mal richtig drauf
geguckt ja das ist komisch also ist es
in der tat so es wird heute ganz ganz
genau darauf geschaut alle
personen die wählen gehen heute wir
haben es bei armin laschet auch gesehen
und jeder der heute ins wahllokal geht
er muss natürlich eine maske tragen das
heißt auch wenn man seinen
personalausweis noch mal zeigt dann
gibt's da erhöhten druck auch noch mal
genau hinzuschauen der ganze prozess
dauert heute deutlich länger als normal
aber natürlich wundert man sich wenn der
kanzlerkandidat kommt und dann also
nochmal richtig genau befragt wird von
denjenigen die im wahllokal ihren dienst
tun ist das jetzt besonders gewissenhaft
gewesen gab es schon andere
unstimmigkeiten wir sind auch gerade
dabei das zu klären aber vollkommen
richtig der hinweis man hätte das auf
jeden fall sehen müssen und den
kanzlerkandidaten noch mal darauf
hinweisen müssen denn jeder weiß wenn
armin laschet die stimme abgibt dann
sind natürlich alle kameras auf diese
waren ohne gerichtet das weiß armin
laschet auch aber noch mal es ist jetzt
nicht überraschend dass er zweimal die
cdu wählt hat ja noch viele viele
anzeigen auch geschaltet gestern in
zeitungen und radio spots also die
überraschende vertrag über sein wird
dieses wird die wahl möglicherweise
angefochten wird seine stimmabgabe
angefochten muss vielleicht am ende
sogar der bundeswahlleiter entscheiden
er hat es möglicherweise eher aus
versehen getan als bewusst und wenn wenn
auch aus versehen klarer verstoß gegen
das wahlgeheimnis so viel kann man jetzt
schon festhalten und ausgerechnet armin
laschet ausgerechnet auch noch auf dem
allerletzten meter es war ja nicht die
erste panne wir haben vorhin ganz kurz
eingeblendet gesehen wie matthias
brügelmann und marcel reif schon warten
die sind bereit und wir berichten hier
den ganzen tag natürlich für sie meine
damen an diesem historischen tag über
die bundestagswahl aber jetzt machen wir
uns erst mal locker mit den beiden
sportlern
[Musik]